[موسيقى]
مساء الخير كاتب وباحث مهتم بالتاريخ
والتراث الاسلامي يرى ان الطريقه التي
يعرض بها هذا التاريخ غالبا ما تتسم بنمط
تقليدي وسرد اخباري للاحداث السياسيه دون
وعي او اهتمام بتفاصيل حياه تلك المجتمعات
يرى ايضا ان تناول التاريخ الاسلامي في
الفضاء العام غالبا ما يصبغ بها لديني
ويتم التعامل معه على انه تاريخي يعبر عن
الصراع بين الخير والشر استاذ الثقافه
الاسلاميه والكاتب الدكتور عبد الله رشيد
في سؤال مباشر حياك الله دكتور دكتور
خليني ابدا معك من مقال كيف نقرا التاريخ
تقول بان الطريق التي يعرض بها التاريخ
الاسلامي غالبا ما يتسم بنمط تقليدي وسرد
اخباري الاحداث السياسيه وتعاقب للدول
والممالك وانه دائما ياتي في قالب وعظي
وديني ويصبغ بهذه الهاله يعني الامر الذي
يشوه تقديم التاريخ برايك لماذا ترى او ما
هي طريقه عبد الله الرشيد اذا في رؤيته
للتاريخ اولا
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الاستضافه
حقيقه انا احب ان اوضح واحد من الازمات
الفكريه في عالمنا العربي هذه الازمات
التي نجدها تظهر في الخطاب الثقافي
والاجتماعي في احوال المجتمعاتنا العربيه
هذه هي الطريقه السلبيه في التعاطي مع
احداث التاريخ وحضور السجال الطائفي
والعقائدي والديني في كثير من جوانب
حياتنا يعني تجد ان لما تاتي فكره جديده
نظريه جديده علوم حديثه بدلا من ان نتناقش
في لب الموضوع نجد ان السجال ديني او
عقائدي او حتى طائفي ياخذنا الى زاويه
بعيده جدا عن هذا الموضوع ثم ندخل في حوار
عقيم بلا ثمره وبلا فائده بل قد يزيد
الفرقه والشقاق ونبتعد عن الموضوع ذو
الفائده هو ابرز مثال على ذلك احداث
التاريخ مع الاسف الشديد من العربي
التاريخ بدلا من ان يكون مصدرا للثراء
والجمال والابداع واستلهام القصاص والعبر
وانتاج الاعمال الدراميه والروايات
الادبيه اصبح حلبه للصراع حلب اهل الشقاق
حلب اهل الشد والجذب تستدعى شخصيات من
الماضي افضت الى بارئها قبل 1400 سنه ثم
نتصارع حولها لماذا هذا لن يساعدنا ابدا
في فهم احداث التاريخ بل قد يسبب في
انفصالنا عن تاريخنا هذا تراثنا هذا جزء
من حضارتنا جزء من من هويتنا هذا الشقاق
والسجال لن يفيدنا الا في انفصالنا عن
تاريخنا ويساهم في تشويه وان يكون تاريخنا
ملبد بطبقات من غيوم الصراع الديني
والطائفي ليش انت مهتم لهذه الدرجه
بالكتابه في التاريخ دكتور يعني الا ترى
انه العوده الى التاريخ البحث دائما فيه
هو في غرق في الماضي بكاء على الاضاءه
للوقت والجهد بلاط نعم حقيقه كثير ما او
اي شخص يهتم بالتاريخ وكثير ما تصلني يعني
اسئله وكده لانه انت غارق في التاريخ انت
غارق في الماضيه انت تبكي على الاطلال
واتفهم هذه الاسئله لكن دعني اوضح لك مثال
على اهميه العنايه بالتاريخ والاهتمام
بالتاريخ هناك مجموعه او او نمط من
الباحثين والاكاديميين في الجامعات
العالميه هؤلاء وظيفتهم ان يتنباوا باحداث
المستقبل كيف يتنبؤوا باحداث المستقبل
هؤلاء المتخصصون في التاريخ هم يعرفون
ويتنبؤون احداث المستقبل من خلال دراسه
التاريخ فهم لدينا حاله معاصره اليوم لا
نفهم كثير من جوانبها وابعادها او ما الذي
سيحدث بعد ذلك يقوم هؤلاء المختصون في
الماضي بدراسه الحالات الشبيهه بها ثم
تنبؤ بالسيناريوهات يقولنا بنسبه كذا وكذا
سوف يحدث التالي هذا هذا اثر عظيم للعنايه
في التاريخ امر اخر مهم يا استاذ خالد في
موضوع مساله العنايه بالتاريخ وبعيدا عن
ازماتنا الثقافيه وسجالاتنا الدينيه
والعقائديه والطائفيه امر مهم اننا حينما
نفهم التاريخ فان هذا هو بمثابه مفتاح
لفهم انفسنا لفهم ذواتنا لماذا لاننا نحن
عباره عن ايش انا وانتم جميع من حولنا
عباره عن تشكل تاريخي تشكل ثقافي
مبادئنا ثقافاتنا قيمنا تقاليدنا عاداتنا
ادابنا فنوننا خيالاتنا حتى الامثال التي
نستخدمها هي تراكم جاء من التاريخ فلما
افهم التاريخ هذا سيساعدني بشكل كبير جدا
اذا فهم نفسي كيف تشكلت شخصيتي وكيف تشكلت
هويتي من المسؤول عن هذه الازمه الفكريه
زي ما ذكرتها في ثقافتنا يعني في قراءتنا
للتاريخ واخرجها عن سياقها
المفروض
الذي جعل من هذا التاريخ حلب للصراع والشد
والجد الذي جعل من هذا التاريخ
ان يكون فعلا مصدر للاثراء والجمال
والتلاحم والترابط هو فعلا هذه الخطابات
الايدولوجيه المتطرفه الجماعات الاصوليه
الجماعات الارهابيه جماعات الاسلام
السياسي التي ارادت فعلا ان تقوم باختطاف
التاريخي ارادت ان تقوم باختطاف التاريخي
لصالحها كيف فعلت ذلك هي قامت صورت لنا
التاريخ الاسلامي انه عباره عن حاله حرب
بين المسلمين والكفار حاله حرب بين
المسلمين والكفار طول الوقت وان هذا
التاريخ هو عباره عن تاريخ عسكري وصراع
ديني وهذا غير صحيح ابدا تاريخ المسلمين
والتاريخ العربي والاسلامي هو ليس صراع
بين المسلمين والكفار
وابرز مثال على ذلك يسقط هذه الشائعه هو
ان حينما تعود الى المدن والعواصم في
تاريخ الحضاره الاسلاميه في الدوله
الامويه والعباسيه ومن بعدهم مثلا بغداد
ودمشق قرطبه سمرقند وغيرها الغالبيه
العظمى من سكان هذه المدن هم من غير
المسلمين من الطوائف الاخرى من غير
المسلمين هم يعيشون ويتع داخل هذه المدن
الاسلاميه بل ابعد من ذلك يعبرون ويحتفلون
بطقوسهم وشعائرهم الدينيه والعقائديه في
العلن بل تذكر يعني يذكر الاستخري في
كتابه المسالك والممالك ان في مدينه الرها
في العصر العباسي قرابه 300 كنيسه تخيل
هذا الرقم اذا كان تاريخنا هو عباره عن
صراع بين المسلمين والكفار كيف يمكن ان
يحدث هذا الامر كيف يمكن ان تكون مثل هذا
التنوع الحضاري والتعايش الديني الموجود
المسؤولين عن توصيل هذه الفكره وقناعه
المجتمعات والاجيال بهذه الاشكاليه يعني
في مناهج الدراسيه في كل هذا هذه الفكره
تغلغلت في اذهان الناس وانتشرت بشكل شائع
في العالم العربي وما الذي حدث هذه
الجماعات الاسلام السياسي قامت برسم حاله
متخيله للتاريخ حاله متخيله للتاريخ غير
غير موجود يوافق اهدافهم ورغباته لماذا
لماذا صنعوا هذا الشيء يريد ان يرسموا
حاله متخيله للتاريخ ثم يقول نحن المعبرين
عن هذا التاريخ نحن من نمثل التاريخ
الاسلامي بناء على هذه الصوره المتخيله ما
الذي حدث ما هو اثار ذلك اثار خطيره جدا
على الوعي الجمعي الجمعي في العالم
الاسلامي الذي حدث ان الناس المتلقين
الذين تاثروا بهذا الخطاب الذي يضخ في
الخطب والمواعظ والندوات والاشرطه والى
اخره الذي حدث ان الناس المتاثرين بهذا
الامر ظنوا ان هذا هو التاريخ الاسلامي او
قالوا نعم هذا هو التاريخ صحيح فظنوا ان
التاريخ عباره عن حاله دينيه مثاليه
ولما تاتي لهم وتقول لا يا جماعه الخير
ترى مو بهذا التاريخنا هذا تاريخنا ليس
بهذا الشكل انت تشوه التاريخ الاسلامي
فسار هناك حاله اختطاف حقيقيه لها لهذا
التاريخ من الجانب اخر هناك ايضا فئات
اخرى رافضه للاسلاميين ورافضه لطرحهم لكن
مع الاسف ايضا ظنوا ان طرحهم للتاريخ
الاسلامي هو هذا هو التاريخ فنفروا ايضا
من تاريخنا قالوا اذا كان هذا التاريخ
الاسلامي فلا نريده صار في كلا الحالتين
حاله انفصال كبيره عن تاريخنا
ونقول هذه الجنايه فكريه وثقافيه كبيره
جدا لماذا لان تاريخنا وتراثنا هو حق لنا
هو حق لهذه الشعوب العربيه والمسلمه في
العالم الاسلامي حقنا وتراثنا لا يحق لاحد
ان يختطفه ويختزله لنفسه نقدر الان نعالج
هذه الحاله يعني
كيف ممكن ان يتم او نقرا هذا التاريخ على
اساس انه مصدر لترى والالهام والابداع
والمعرفه عكس هذه الصوره
المشوهه ربما بين قوسين التي وصلت الينا
الحقيقه هذا طبعا موضوع كبير جدا وكثير من
الباحثين والمؤرخين والفلاسفه حاولوا
مناقشه هذا الامر لكن هو ممكن نقول انا من
وجهه نظري الشخصيه من وجهه نظري الخاصه
يعني هو انه اذا اردنا ان نستلهم وناخذ
العبر من التاريخ وان نتحول التاريخ الى
ماده رحبه وواسعه وخلاقه وجميله ومد قد
تكون للتسليه للابداع الى غير ذلك هو اولا
يجب ان نتوقف عن اصدار الاحكام يجب ان
نبتعد عن محاوله القفز لاصدار الحكم
والاستعجال على اخذ مواقف مسبقه تجاه اي
شيء دعونا نقرا التاريخ باعتباره صفحه من
الماضي صفحه ذهبت
نحن لسنا مسؤولين عما حدث وليس من وظيفتنا
ان نجعله لا جميلا ولا شريرا ولا سي
هو علينا ان نقرا هذا التاريخ الهدف
الاساسي اولا هو الفهم الفهم من اجل فهم
ان نفهم ما الذي حدث وكيف حدث وكيف جرى
وان التاريخ والمجتمعات السابقه هي مثلها
مثل المجتمعات بشريه يحدث فيها الخير
والشر والجميل والقبيح ونقرا بهذا التنوع
الكبير ونستلهم منه هذه العبر بعد ذلك
حينما نفهم ونصل للفهم ممكن ان نتناقش وان
نتداول هذا الامر اما ان يتحول التاريخ
الى حلبه للصراع فان لن نستفيد ولن نفهم
حقيقه ما جرى في الماضي واحد من الامثله
على هذه الحلبه للصراع هو معاويه احتدم
الجدل مؤخرا حول شخصيه معويه ابن ابي
سفيان
اعلنت مجموعه ام بي سي تقديم هذا العمل
يتناول سيره هذا الصحابي الجليل في شهر
رمضان
مباشره انطلق شد والجذب والسجال حول هذا
العمل من دوافع مختلفه كتبت مقالا في هذا
الموضوع كيف حجب السجال الطائفي الاهميه
او اهميته التاريخيه تتحدث عن معاويه بن
ابي سفيان اولا كيف اثر هذا الامر السجال
الطائفي والعقائدي من وجهه نظر الدكتور
عبدالله رشيد على شخصيه معاويه بن ابي
يوسف
حقيقه هذا الامر اللي هو السجال الطائفي
والعقائدي يظهر باوضح صوره حينما نتحدث عن
شخصيات معاويه بن ابي سفيان وعن الدوله
الامويه ايضا يعني اعطيك مثال يكفيك الان
ان تقول اسم معاويه فقط دون ان تتكلم شيء
انت لم تقل اي شيء انت بس فقط اسم معاويه
فجاه يشتعل السجال والجدال والاخذ والرد
وبين محب وكاره وفي كل مكان
طيب يا جماعه انا لسه ما قلت شيء
يعني لسه المسلسل ما عرض لم يعرض المسلسل
ولم يعرف احد ماذا يتكلم
هذا هو صوره من صور
المواقف المسبقه والمغلقه تجاه احداث
التاريخ او حتى احداث الحياتيه اليوميه
هذا هذا السجال الطائفي تسبب في يعني يعني
ظلم معرفي وحجب عنا الاطلاع الثقافي
والثراء المعرفي الواسع الذي ممكن ان
نستلهمه من دراسه ومعرفه شخصيه معاويه بن
ابي سفيان انا من رايي واقولها انه شخصيه
معاويه بن ابي سفيان حقيقه هو واحد من
اعظم عباقره السياسه في تاريخ العالم وليس
في التاريخ الاسلامي فحسب واحد من اعظم
عباقره وصناع السياسات في العالم قد تقول
ان هذا الكلام مبالغه كيف هذا الكلام انا
اقول لك هذا الكلام ليس مبالغ كيف نعرف
اثر الشخص السياسي واثره العظيم ونجعله
من الشواهد الحاضر هذه ممكن نناقش دكتور
عبد الله اكيد خلال حوارنا لكن
انت الجدل هذا اللي دار هل هو منطلق ديني
عقائدي ولا سياسي كما يرى الباح
انا اعتقد انه في مثل هذه المسائل يختلط
الامرين لسياسه بالدين والسياسي والعقائدي
والطائفي والديني والثقافي هي مساله مركبه
ومعقده والحقيقه يعني كثير من الافكار
والاتجاهات هي تبدا في البدايه من منطلقات
سياسيه تبدا من منطلقات السياسيه ثم مع
مرور الوقت تتحول الى عقائد وهذا يعني جزء
كبير من تشكل الفرق والطوائف والمذاهب في
الاسلام في بدايتها كانت لاسباب سياسيه
وبعد ذلك تحولت الى جوانب عقائديه لكن في
جزء من هذا السجال ليس المقصود هو الشخصيه
التاريخيه القديمه احيانا هذا السجال
الطائفي الذي يغلف بانه صناعه علاقه شخصيه
تاريخيه هو ليس من اجل الشخصيه التاريخيه
اجل مثلا اعطيك مثال حينما تسمع مثلا في
بعض الشوارع او في بعض المدن وفي
المظاهرات صيحات طائفيه او لعنات توجه
لشخصيات تاريخيه مثلا لعنات الى بني اميه
مثلا وتسمعها في بعض الشوارع وبعض المدن
هذه اللعنات او الطائفيه هل المقصود فيها
فعلا شخصيات قديمه قبل
1400 سنه افضت الى بارئها
مقصود منه اعلان تمايز طائفي ومذهبي ترسيخ
هويه طائفيه معينه في صراعات الحاضر
يستخدم فيها التاريخ في هذا الصراع اذا
التاريخ اصبح اداه لصراعاتنا المعاصره وهو
نفس السبب اللي خلى مثلا شخصيه دينيه مثل
مقتدى الصدر في العراق يصدر بيان حول
المسلسل رغم انه لم يعرض خليني اسمع منك
الاجابه بعد ثقافه القصير دكتور عبد الله
فاصل نعود للمتابعه في سؤال مباشر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في سؤال مباشر ضيفي هو
الكاتب
والباحث في ثقافه الاسلاميه دكتور عبد
الله رشيد دكتور عبد الله حياك الله
اذا المنطلقات العقائديه والمذهبيه هي
كانت السبب في اثاره هذا الجدل حول
والطائفيه ايضا في ذره الجدل حول حول
معاويه هذا السبب هو الذي جعل شخصيه مثل
مقتدى الصدر شخصيه دينيه شخصيه سياسيه
يصدر بيان حول هذا المسلسل حتى نقبل لم
يعد يعني بعد هذا هو نفس اشتمال للجمهور
للكسب السياسي كما يرى الاخر ممكن هناك
ممكن هناك دوافع كثيره يعني كثير من
الاحداث والاشياء والبيانات والاعلانات
لها دوافع اخرى متنوعه غير الدافع
المقصود الظاهر في في العلن لكن هذه هذا
المثال وهذا النموذج الذي ذكرته هو جزء من
الازمه الفكريه الثقافيه التي نعاني منها
في العالم العربي انت كيف تحذر من عمل انت
لم يخرج الى العالم قبل يعني انت افترضت
يعني سوء النيه الان وخلت موقف مسبق قبل
ان يخرج هذا العمل وهذه هي الاشكاليه
الثقافيه في عالم العربي انا اعيد واكد
انها اشكاليه ثقافيه لانها تغلف بغلاف
ديني فاحنا يجب ان نعيدها الى الجانب
الثقافي بمعنى هذا حدث تاريخي من حقي ان
اروي روايه قصه تاريخيه عن هذا الحدث ومن
حق الجميع ان نتناقش حوله وناخذ ما الذي
دار حول هذا الشان لكن دعونا نستمع اولا
دعونا نقرا احداث التاريخ دعونا ان نعرض
اما ان يكون هناك حاله من التحريض
والترهيب والرفض المصحف هذا هو جزء من
ازمه الخطابات الطائفيه
الضخ المتشنج
للرؤى الدينيه المنغلقه خليني اخذ معك بعض
الامثله يعني في مقالك في المكان في مجله
المجله حول معاويه بن ابي سفيان البعض يرى
بانه انت بالغت في توصيف هذه الشخصيه بشكل
كبير قدمتها ربما كما يرى البعض وينتقد
هذا المقال بانه شخصيه معصومه عن الخطا
يعني
ليس من العدل ان يقدم هذا الشخص منه انسان
طبيعي صوره بشريه عاديه يعني مش زي ما
بلغته انا اللي انا ما كنت اهدف الي حقيقه
هو ان نبتعد عن السجال الديني عن تناول
شخصيه معاويه بن ابي سفيان رضي الله عنه
بعيدا عن الجانب الديني الذي يحدث في هذا
السجال ونقدمه بشخصيته البشريه الطبيعيه
بمنجزاته الحضاريه السياسيه هذا هو الهدف
عكس تماما ما ذكرت فاريد ان اذكر شخصيه
معاويه بن ابي سفيان ما هو اثرها الحضاري
الثقافي الاجتماعي الاقتصادي في تاريخنا
هذا الاثر كيف اثر على جميع الناس على
جميع الطوائف بكل اشكالهم والوانهم حتى
الذي حتى المختلفين معه هذا هو المقصود من
هذا المقال وذلك حرصت في هذا الموضوع انا
اتحدث عن ما هو اثر ومنجزات معاويه بن ابي
سفيان في جانب السياسه في جانب الاقتصاد
في جانب تاسيس الدوله العربيه الاسلاميه
التي يعني اسست امبراطوريه كبرى في العالم
في ذلك الوقت وكانت الدوله الامويه
ومعاويه بدعم السفيان هو احد من وضع ركائز
حقيقه النظام السياسي العربي الذي كل من
جاء بعده
استلهموا واستفادوا والتزموا بهذه الطريقه
يعني انت استخدمت مفردات سياسيه يعني
اعاده صياغه المشهد العالمي انت تتكلم عن
قيام الدوله الامويه على يد بن ابي سفيان
وصفت بين لحظه مدويه في صفحات التاريخ
اعادت صيغه المشهد العالمي غير من موازين
القوى رسم خريطه جديده لقارات يعني
كيف كيف وصلت لهذه القناعه بناء هذا
الكلام حقيقه غير مبالغه الناس يمكن
يشوفوا يقول هذا مبالغ او حاله وعاطفه لا
الحقيقه هذا الكلام
عن سفيان ماذا يعني فعلا هذا الرجل هذا
الرجل معاويه بن ابي سفيان هذا الشاب
اليافع اللامع الذي نشا بين بطحاء مكه
وجبالهم ابن سيد سادات قريش هذا الرجل
الذي خرج الى الشام في ظل احداث مضطربه
وملتهبه كانت في العالم الاسلامي بعد
احداث الفتنه قام معاويه بن ابي سفيان في
ذلك الوقت بحمايه وحفظ المنجزات الحضاريه
التاريخيه التي تحققت في عهد الخلافه
الراشده فاسس معاويه بن ابي سفيان واحده
من اكبر واعظم الامبراطوريات التي عرفها
البشر في زمانهم في ذلك الوقت التي هي
الدوله الامويه الامبراطوريه هذه الدوله
الامويه كانت اكبر بثلاثه اضعاف يعني
حجمها اكبر بثلاثه اضعاف من الامبراطوريه
الرومانيه هذه الدوله الدوله الامويه بلغ
نفوذها وامتد نفوذها الى جميع قارات الارض
المعروفه بذلك الوقت اسيا واوروبا
وافريقيا هذه الدوله حكمت الثلث العالم
نحن نتحدث عن ثلث العالم حكمت هذه الدوله
وتحت يعني سكانها بلغوا 60 مليون نسمه
وهذا عدد ضخم بمعايير ذلك الزمن نتكلم عن
رجل اسس هذه الامبراطوريه التي غيرت من
شكل العالم حكمت قرابه ثلث العالم اذا هذه
الخريطه الكبرى التي غيرت هذا الشكل وهذا
العالم
والى اليوم امتداداتها قائمه بمعنى صوره
العالم الاسلامي بشكل وشكل خريطه العالم
الاسلامي تقريبا هو تعود بشكل كبير الى
تلك انت ذكرت انه دور في حفظ الطوائف
المسيحيه العربيه كيف
له اثر كبير جدا في هذا في هذا الجانب
وحتى نفهم هذا الامر اولا من نتكلم عن
معاويه كخليفه للمسلمين معاويه بصفته
اميرا للشام ثم خليفه المسلمين حينما
اصبحت دمشق عاصمه الخلافه الامويه هو لم
يكن فقط قائدا وزعيما للمسلمين فحسب هو
كان ايضا مرجعا ومسؤولا وحاميا للطوائف من
غير المسلمين الموجوده في في العالم
الاسلامي كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل انه العالم
الاسلامي المدن في العالم الاسلامي كان
فيها نسبه كبيره بل ربما في حلب في عالم
الحالات هم الاكثريه
غير المسلمين فلذلك اذا نسبه كبيره من
سكان البلاد من غير المسلمين كان معاويه
هو بمثابه المرجع الذي تعود اليه هذه
الطوائف المسيحيه بل انه في المصادر
المسيحيه تطلق على معاويه بن او سفيان لقب
الزعيم المستنير السمح وكانت هذه الطوائف
المسيحيه حينما تختلف فيما بينها اختلفت
مثلا طائفه العاقبه والمارونيه وغيرهم حول
مساله طبيعه المسيح يرجعون الى معاويه بن
ابي سفيان هو الذي يفصل بينهم في هذه
المسائل
ويفض هذا النزاع وهذا فض النزاع هو حمايه
لهذه الطوائف من ان تتقاتل فيما بينها
معين بن سفيان كان وزير ماليته مسيحي كان
طبيبه الخاص مسيحي كان شاعره في البلاط
مسيحي وعين واليا على حمص مسيحي اسمه ابن
اثال وهذا مشهد حضاري غيبته عنا هذه
الخطابات انت تقول انه هذه الدوله
تحت يعني معاويه رجل السياسه بل احد اهم
رجال السياسه والملك في تاريخ الانسانيه
اصبحت نموذجا لكل من جاءت بعدها كل الدول
والمالك الاسلاميه اتفق في ذلك كاره
ومحبوه التزموا منهجه في الحكم كيف
التزموا
وضع نظاما سياسيا كل من جاءوا بعده من
الدول والممالك في العالم الاسلامي كلها
استمرت عليه الدوله الامويه وضعت نظما
ودواوين من جاءوا بعدهم له يعودون اليهم
فقط وسعوا ويعودون الى هذا الاساس عفوا
هذا النظام الذي وضعه معايا بن ابي سفيان
هو انه حينما حدثت احداث الفتنه
والاضطرابات كان لابد من وضع نظام سياسي
وتاسيس نظام سياسي ينقذ العالم الاسلامي
من الاضطراب والتفكك فاسس معاويه ابن ابي
سفيان اول عائله ملكيه وراثيه تحكم في
تاريخ الاسلام هناك ناس غاضبوا كثيرا من
هذا النظام وانه تغيير في نظام حكم
الخلافه الراشده جميل من حقك ان تختلف مع
اي نظام سياسي ولكن كل الدول العباسيه بعد
ذلك
التي بعد الدوله الامويه اخذت بهذا التزمت
بنفس النهج
كلها دول ملكيه وراثيه وتسمي نفسها ايضا
بنفس الاسم على اسم
الدوله الامويه ثم الدوله العباسيه ثم
الدوله الفاطميه ايضا وهم دوله وهم
اسماعيليه الشيعه مع ذلك التزموا بهذا
النظام الذي وضعه معاويه اذا كان لديهم
مشكله مع هذا النظام حقيقيه وهذا النظام
لم يكن ناجح فعلا في ذلك الوقت لماذا
حينما كان لهم الامر لماذا لم يغيروه
لماذا لم يلغوه الحقيقه انها كان نظام
ناجح وانقذ العالم الاسلامي من وين جبت
النسبه مثلا انت تقول
هو من اسس وضع النظم الدواوين طور الجيوش
القوات البحريه بين السدود طور انظمه
الراي الراي تقول انه اسس اول جهاز
استخبارات في التاريخ الاسلامي كان يسمى
ديوان البريد على ماذا اعتمد في مصادرك
دكتور عبد الله للوصول الى هذه هذه
الاحكام المعلومات التي تحدث عن دور
معاويه في تاسيس هذه النظم والدواوين هي
ما توا عليه كثير من المؤرخين في المصادر
الاصيله والمصادر الكلاسيكيه في التاريخ
الاسلامي نتحدث عن الطبري ابن كثير وابن
كثير والبلاذري والمسعودي وكثير ممن كتبوا
عن سيره وتاريخ الدوله الامويه حتى من
مناويي الدوله الامويه هم يؤكدون على دور
معاويه بن سفيان في تاسيس مثل هذه الامور
ومن اشهر هذه المؤلفات هناك نمط في
التاليف كتب الاوائل والتي تتحدث عن اول
من فعل كذا اول من فعل كذا من ابرزها مثلا
كتاب الاوائل لا بهلال العسكري وفيه فصل
الاوائل في الملك وفي هذا الفصل ياتي
معاويه بن ابي سفيان رضي الله عنه اول ملك
في الاسلام اول من وضع نظام ديوان البريد
اول من وضع الديوان الختم وهكذا هذه كلها
معلومات
متوافره وتوافر واكدها كثير من المؤرخين
والباحثين في مصادر التاريخ الاسلامي
الاصيله اعظم ملوك العرب
هذا الامر او هذا
الامر او هذا اللقب انه اعظم ملوك العرب
يعني اش اليه وذكره عدد من المحققين
والعلماء السابقين ذكروا بهذا اللفظ ونص
على ان معاب الاسفان هو اعظم ملوك العرب
ونحن ممكن نقول انه فعلا هو واحد من اعظم
من اعظم ملوك العرب التي اثروا الدكتور
جورج صليبه يمكن هو كذلك
واهم خليفه اموي مرعب لا اعلم اذا كان هو
له راي مخالف في هذا الشان او شيء لكنه هو
ايضا عبد الملك بن مروان شخصيه عظيمه جدا
ومؤثره في التاريخ الاسلامي يؤثر عظيم
وائل وهو المؤسس الثاني للدوله الامويه
واثاره هائله في بناء ايضا الحضاره
العربيه والاسلاميه اللي يسمعك بهذه
الطريقه تصف معاويه يعني انت تشوف وتسمع
انه انت بالغت كثيرا وربما انه انت تشترك
مع الناس هذول في في بهذا الطرح الكبير
بهذا التعصب وتاخذها من منطلق كذلك ديني
ربما ما رايك في هذا
كل ما تحدثت معه اشعر بانني لم من منطلقات
دينيه وانما حاولت ان اقدم شواهد بمصادر
مثل المصادر
التاريخيه
تاريخ الطبري تاريخ ابن الاثير تاريخ ابن
كثير
كما يقال لها اتفق عليها العلماء
والمؤرخون انا كل ما ذكرت لك ربما لا ترى
في اي جانب ديني هو مجرد احداث دنيويه
احداث دنيويه وشواهد تؤكد حول الاثر
الحضاري التي صنعته هذا الشخصيه
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد الله الثقافه
الاسلاميه شكرا جزيلا شكرا دائما يمكنكم
متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر فيسبوك يوتيوب والاستماع الى هذه
الحلقه ومشاهدتها على شاهدوا على العربيه
[موسيقى]